[Music]
[Applause]
albert breer joining us senior nfl
reporter always smarter after we hear
from albert uh monday morning
quarterback nbc boston joining us from
tampa what was the feeling like there
before and then the feeling after that
game albert
i mean before i think most people were
talking about brady and whether this was
his last um game or could be his last
game obviously we didn't know at the
time um afterwards
you know i i still have that in the back
of my head that he's going to play one
more year and and i think he's going to
think about it and i think he has other
things to consider
um you know her family is certainly a
part of it you know he's got a son who i
believe will be going into high school
next year that son lives in new york
um yeah everything you hear from
everybody who's close to him he's a
great dad
and so like there are some things that i
think are going to weigh on him
um but
you know that magic number of 45 it's
not an arbitrary number for him and so
um you know i i think he can still do it
and the one thing that's sort of i i
think he's always established that line
of demarcations i don't want to go out
there and suck
and i don't think he sucks like i think
he's still pretty good and i think we
can all envision a pretty good tom brady
going out there and playing one last
year in 2022. the key to me is going to
be what tampa does because if you look
at tampa right now ryan jensen's a free
agent
carl davis is a free agent chris
godwin's a free agent leonard
fournette's a free agent rob gronkowski
is a free agent and they've mortgaged so
many of these contracts they do have
some space to work with next year but i
think to bring the band back together
it's going to take a lot of people
taking a little bit less and you have to
at least account for the fact that a guy
like chris godwin who's been waiting to
get his big second contract probably
isn't going to do that so
i think there are a lot of factors that
are going to come into play here over
the next month or so as tom brady makes
his decision and then for the rams man i
think it's vindication for the staffer
trade i mean i think you know in those
last whatever it was 25 seconds you saw
why they traded for matthew stafford and
oh by the way i think the game that
followed right i think that shows why
you trade for matthew stafford too
because i think if you don't have a guy
like that right now like that game last
night that af that afc division will
play playoff between buffalo and kansas
city has to give you nightmares i mean
if i'm anybody in the afc right now
outside of maybe the chargers and the
bengals and i'm looking at that i'm like
taking a second look at what i have at
quarterback because i mean you're
looking up a mountain right now and it's
almost like patrick mahomes cooled off
enough that we moved on to the next
quarterback and we forgot like if it's
it's possible that he's underrated
we he reminded us last night that he
still can do things that maybe no other
quarterback in the nfl can do
you know what's interesting about it dan
is i think like what we sort of forget
too is there's still room for growth
there which is the scary thing about
home right like he's already been to two
super bowls he's won a super bowl he's
won an mvp he accomplished so much over
his fourth year for his first four years
one of which he didn't even play in
right that like going into year five i
think we just looked at him as this
finished product and so when it didn't
look perfect earlier in the year you
sort of forget the fact that the guy is
26 years old and i remember talking to
some defensive coaches over the course
of september and october like what's
wrong with the chief's offense what's
going on what are they doing it's like
defenses are challenging him in
different ways and he's got to learn to
evolve a little bit and that stuff was
real you know like teams were playing
two high safeties against him and
challenging him to go 10 plays 12 plays
14th place we saw buffalo do at the
start of the game a little bit yesterday
too you know and so
i think he had to develop that part of
his game a little bit more and to his
credit he's done it you know and i think
like that's the one thing that i think
sometimes we look at with mahomes and we
sort of forget
is that he's still really young he came
into the league really raw he only spent
three years in college he's still just
26 years old and there was room for
growth and i think over the course this
year through some of those struggles in
the middle of the year we have seen that
growth and i think all of it sort of
came together yesterday against buffalo
feels like there was an outcry to change
over time because
we loved the bill's story like the
lovable bills they got a chance to go to
the afc title game again
and
like if tom brady had lost in overtime i
don't think anybody would be shouting
for the mountaintops we need to change
this but it felt like because the bills
lost we hate the overtime rule the team
that wins the toss
in in the playoffs in overtime i think
is only lost once
uh it has there been something on the
table with the competition committee
with changing overtime
yeah i mean they've talked about the
idea of having so the chiefs brought
this up um and brought this to the table
that each team should have at least one
possession
and then if it's tied after one
possession go sudden death after that
and a lot of people look through that as
sour grapes um because it came right in
the heel of the same thing happening to
kansas city in the afc championship game
and you remember the scenario was almost
identical right like if you remember
that game what happened in that game was
it was a heavyweight bout between two
great quarterbacks and in the end
the defenses were completely out of gas
i mean you remember that dan like d ford
was offsides because it was just you
felt like the defenses had given
everything they could and they were
completely out of gas and i think it was
the same thing here if buffalo gets the
ball kansas city's defense is out of gas
and it happens to the chiefs again you
know and so
i i see both sides of this and i think
it's a difficult one because on one end
the the competition committee in the
league have been trying to limit the
amount of damage that goes on to
football players bodies and that's why
they went from 15-minute overtime to
10-minute overtime so they don't want to
have 20 25 30 minute overtimes in in in
the playoffs they they just because of
the players saving help and save you
stuff you've got that i also understand
where people are saying well it's not
like one of these things where you just
need 30 yards anymore right like you
need you need to go 75 yards in most
cases to score so if you can't stop them
you deserve to lose i understand all
that
i also sort of understand where the
rules now are so tilted towards the
offense and we're seeing these just worn
out defenses in these situations where
it does feel a little bit like it's a
fade accompli
when kansas city wins the talks that
they're going to go right down the field
and i believe they only face one-third
down going down the field right which is
very much like the ease with which the
patriots went down the field on the
chiefs three years ago
we're talking to albert breer senior nfl
reporter lead content strategist for the
monday morning quarterback let's look at
the losing teams and the quarterbacking
situation you think brady's back next
year probably i'm not a hundred percent
but i i think that like he winds up
i mean you know he has a boss just like
me and you have bosses so he's gonna go
home and check with the boss but
um you know i i
i like i i think ultimately he i think
ultimately
like there's gonna i think he comes to
some sort of agreement with the bucks
where he can play one more year um and i
think that like he's sort of figured it
out in the off season we're gonna spend
enough time around his family
uh but you know i don't think anything's
for certain right now and i think he
does want to see what the bucks plan is
all right aaron rodgers says he played
his last game in green bay
this is really tough because the the i
mean all that stuff i said about the box
and the situation they're in i think
it's worse with the ra with the with the
packers i mean not only are they you
know almost 50 million dollars over the
cap for next year they also
got to figure out what to do with aaron
rodgers best receiver and maybe his best
friend on the team and davonte adams and
they're sort of a package deal so
i think you i think
they've made a lot of progress towards
potentially being together in 2022.
what complicates it to me is the fact
that i think it would require doing a
new contract to do that because the
packers aren't going to go into a
contract year with him and risk losing
him for nothing in 2023
and so can you figure out the contract
can you figure out a way to manage the
cap situation are you willing to
mortgage all
you know
a couple more years to make it work for
another single year and then what do you
do beyond that you know it's just it's
become so complicated because they did
so much to make it work this year the
good news is i do think some of the
relationship mending has happened and
you've heard him talk about brian gouda
kunst who i mean like i think you know
that relationship was in a really really
bad place seven eight nine months ago i
think it's in a much better place now
and i think matt lafleur deserves a lot
of credit for facilitating that so i do
think that there's there's a path here
even if it's a little bit of a narrow
one just because of the circumstances
and the logistics of the team
the titans with ryan tannahill
that's tough you know his contracts is
his uh his money for next year is
guaranteed so he is his base salary of
29 million dollars for next year's
guaranteed
the only path i see out of this dan
is like doing what the chiefs did um you
know when they had alex smith
i think because of their cap situation
the only way you can really do it
um if you're the titans
i mean unless you find somebody to take
on that contract with the rams found you
know the lines amenable to the idea of
taking on jared goff's contract and
that's a totally different thing jared
goff's 10 years younger than ryan
tannehill um
unless you can find somebody to take on
that contract i think the only way to
sort of reset a quarterback right now is
to do what the chiefs did and spend the
next couple years
just working the college ranks and
trying to find somebody that you really
like and the trouble is like right now
there's not that obvious answer like if
you talk to enough college scouts like
this is one of the weakest quarterback
classes coming in um in 10 to 15 years
and maybe we all look stupid for saying
that in a few years i don't know but
that's just burdens right now
and then
i don't know that there's like that
trevor lawrence on the horizon either
like you look 23 24 i mean someone's
gonna be there but i'm not sure that
there's like this this great
quarterbacking hope on the horizon in
the college level as it stands right now
yeah it's kind of interesting that you
know when do you do it and
trying to get somebody and then you know
kansas city went
they
they waited until the very last second i
think to go up and get mahomes because
this could have all changed if sean
payton
you know if patrick mahomes was there
sean was taking patrick mahomes yeah i
mean they were worried about i mean
i mean you look at the chiefs who are
concerned about the cardinals at 13
and the saints 11. and i have it on good
authority that the saints were taking
him at 11. they wound up getting a
really good player marshawn lattimore
but that was patrick from homes you
imagine the landscape of the nfl would
be a whole lot different right now and
oh by the way who was it that traded
andy reid that draft pit michonne
mcdermott
ouch uh yeah sean payton told uh you
know when i asked him i said were you
taking the homes he said yes that uh
that that we were
uh is sean done in new orleans
um
i
don't think so i think he's going to get
offers
from places like fox and amazon
that are going to entice him
i think he's making so much money now in
new orleans and has such a comfortable
situation in new orleans
i i just think like he's probably like i
think he's eventually gonna be in tv
um but i think like for right now
i think he'd be he's comfortable going
back to the saints and again i think
he'll eventually be in tv and maybe this
is like a 60 40 thing for me right now
um i wrote about this back you know um
at the end of the regular season like i
had heard it was a possibility in
november and december um you know like i
don't think the bears like although i
think the bears really you know did
discuss the idea of trading for sean
payton
sean payton didn't want to go there
because he had misgivings about
ownership and everything else i do think
the tv thing like his enticing for him
but ultimately i think because of
like like because of a few different
factors that go into that job in new
orleans where he has things
like really where he's got a lot of
control and he can run the show there
he's making really good money i think he
winds up going back for at least another
year what about dallas
and that's the thing you know like but
but here's like what's the 10 my
question with dallas like right i think
like sean could take a year off and then
wind up in dallas next year like i think
that's possible the thing to me about
dallas is what's the tension point now
um more than a week after the cowboy
season ended
to push jerry to go and fire mike
mccarthy because he's not just gonna
wait forever for sean payton right like
i i i think that at some point you've
got to move on
to me like the one tension point that
gets my book that gets
jerry jones to like really think about
doing something on mike mccarthy would
be losing dan quinn and that's going to
come to a head probably in the next
couple of days he's a finalist
in denver i think he's still the
front-runner for that job in denver um
he's in new york today interviewing with
the giants that's where he's from
um and i think that the giants really
sort of are intrigued by the idea of
bring him in he could have multiple
offers and um so like i think this is
something that stephen and jerry jones
have really had to think about
is they love dan quinn he's better than
they even thought he would be when they
hired him they think he can they think
he's gonna be a really good head coach
again they saw the way he changed their
defense they saw him develop young
talent like micah parsons and trayvon
diggs now the question is are if you're
jerry and steven are you willing to let
dan quinn walk out the door
to keep mike mccarthy
and do you want to face the prospect
of mike mccarthy without dan quinn now
maybe they go out and get mike zimmer if
they lose quinn which i'd expect they
will lose quinn uh but i think it's
certainly given jerry and steven
something to think about over the last
week
i'll leave you with this the team that
could afford both rogers and devante
adams
because
looking at the cap room
uh
and i don't know what denver's cap
situation is but i've been on that you
know since they traded von miller they
were loading up to send draft picks to
the cowboys but you know the dolphins
dolphins got
i think 67 million dollars in cap space
you move on from tua
um
you're not going to trade for watson
i i don't know
is that a possibility yeah it's a fun
idea yeah i mean i think it's a fun idea
wait are you just being nice to me is
that what you're doing right now
that's a cute little story i'm not okay
i'm not patronizing anybody here i i i
uh no i no i i like the i i like the
idea of it um because
i do think
i don't want to compare to a deteba
but like it's sort of remember like what
it was like with tebow in um in denver
where he'd won the playoff game and he
had a lot of backing um in the city and
there were people in the organization
who liked him and he was good for
business in denver and they needed to do
something
like the football people needed to do
something big
to have the ability to move off of tebow
so what did they do they went and got
peyton manning right
like maybe that's it maybe it's if we're
gonna move off of tua it needs to be
with a big swing and maybe that big
swing's aaron rodgers they were in the
market for deshaun watson so it's not
impossible the one question i would have
is how much it appeals to aaron to go
there but if you're saying you're
bringing devonte adams with you maybe
that's the carrot i still think like
denver would be the big i'm with you on
the on the broncos i still think that
that's the best possibility i i think
that's why nate hackett um has been
somebody they've looked into is now a
finalist for their head coaching job i
also think it's why
you know in interviewing dan quinn
another guy they interviewed was luke
dex getzy the passing game coordinator
from green bay who i think like would
actually probably be that was actually
probably more of an offensive
coordinator hire where i think their
plan a might be dan quinn as head coach
luke gets his offensive coordinator
aaron rodgers coming in as the
quarterback
safe travels back from tampa albert
thank you
all right thanks dan appreciate it
that's albert breer
it felt like he was kind of tapping me
on the head and saying that's a cute
little uh little thing but leave it to
the insiders here